um
so much to unpack here about season two
i want to start with the biggest
cliffhanger of them all
john b's dad is alive
how is john b going to react to that
chase
when he finds out and what does that
mean for season three
man i had the same question i when i
read that in the script i
i had an inkling because we left enough
little easter eggs i felt like in season
one
but we didn't know at the time right
like it was fully by the time we
finished season one went into season two
there was
no conversation about his dad being
alive so
when we got that script i was like
oh my gosh this changes everything you
know this whole journey
and then the fact that limbree and his
dad
know each other how does it was just i
didn't know
how to process i felt like my internal
circuits we're just shutting down so
i'm excited to see where it goes i'm
excited to see how that impacts
everything
and how does that change john b's
dynamic you know is he going to accept
it is he not
is he going to open up with his son
about what he was doing and how he was
involved with these people
i just think it opened so many doors so
i'm excited
maddie for you i feel like sarah had the
most heartbreaking
journey this season from watching her
dad
seemingly died to realizing he is still
alive
her brother shot her tried to drown her
what did you make of of sarah's journey
overall this season and what does her
family dynamic
look like moving forward i don't even
know
um i i don't know it was a lot to
navigate
um i'm you know i'm really lucky to play
that dynamic across
from drew starkey and chip esten
because they're they're just so
incredibly specific within their
intentions and
you know their direction they're
incredible to work
opposite of but uh i don't i think for
me
i mean and i i'm pretty sure sarah is on
the same page
like just done like done with that
it's a show um so
you know i feel like i feel like at this
point it's
you know for her it's no no-brainer that
you know
home is the people around her
and that's the pogues and so i you know
i'd really love to see her
gain like independence and like complete
independence in herself
and um and uh find home elsewhere
speaking of home john b and sarah did
get married
when are they gonna start telling more
people uh they didn't they didn't really
tell a lot of people did they it was
like they told the ex-boyfriend
and he didn't even say he didn't even
tell the ex-girlfriend
i just was wondering like are we gonna
get a full wedding in season three i
feel like they deserve that
you know i think that they deserve all
of the
relaxing time after you know everything
that they've gone through
it was interesting i mean like they they
made the comment and then
you're kind of like oh wow that just
kind of flew over a lot of people's
heads but
um i think that's the john beans here
away a little bit
you know yeah i think so okay i feel
like it'd be really fun in season three
you know if we're if we get one to see
them actually start to
like truly get to know each other like
in a very
real sense like they're married but
they actually kind of don't know a whole
lot about each i feel like that would be
really fun
yeah um
or you know just i feel like you know
like sarah tries to
in the um in a total rachel green moment
sarah tries to
bake a cake and puts like peas and beef
in it and it's like here babe and he's
like for you
[Laughter]
do you guys think 16 is too young for
them
to be married and do you guys in your
real lives
talk about marriage or do you just leave
that to the john b and sarah of it all
um i definitely think 16. well look
everybody has their own experience right
like it works for some people i mean
we've seen
couples who got married at 16 who are
now in their 80s and
you know sure 90s who are still together
and yeah
wildly in love so i don't think that the
age
should specifically define it i think
love is something that
should move that needle and yeah
love is love i think we're trying to
yeah you're going through it
right like this is just a crazy
experience for them
like they've gotten married they've had
everything that's happened in the
bahamas and then everything after that i
think
it's a it'll be an interesting thing to
move forward from and i'm excited to see
kind of like what matt said
you know what is it like when they
finally get a second to get to know each
other
right and really have the questions yeah
i feel like that's a really endearing
part about love
and i also think when you know you know
i love that that is true though when you
know you know
we did see a few hiccups for john b and
sarah
especially when jealousy came into play
who handles conflict better john b and
sarah or chase
and maddie i do i put us in the column
i think we're better john b is such a
little sour puss like he's always
getting so
pissed about the dumbest things like it
was such a harmless thing obviously like
there's the you know toxic masculinity
going on between topper and john b
in that moment but it was like a simple
act of kindness and
obviously sarah doesn't deserve anything
of what john b does
in that moment and uh you know he he
definitely
needs to work on his attitude i think me
and john b need to have a talk
yeah go back and just say hey man you
need to you need to stop being a jealous
little boy
i don't know although i feel like it was
so i mean like sometimes
like i mean i've had moments where i've
been incredibly jealous
and and very petty and it's over like
nothing huge and like i feel like i mean
even though
he was being such a pill i feel like
sometimes that's incredibly real though
like sometimes you know you just
can't help it i think it was less at
sarah moore topper you know what i mean
like
i'm sorry yeah and that's what i mean
with john b
like john b is always sort of misfiring
he's like i'm going to aim right here
and then i'm going to accidentally shoot
all the way to the right and just get it
completely missed
so funny everyone uh does think that the
pogues
are missing carla lambre is still out
there
are they going to barbados since season
three have you heard about
what's next for them what we don't have
no idea um that is just as much a
question mark to us as it is to everyone
else so we're just
excited to find out is there anything
that you would love to see explored
in season three for each of you chase
yeah i think um you know what is this
dynamic with john b and his father gonna
be like
you know he's been sort of manically
chasing this
idea of getting his father back and not
believing that he's alive
for you know a while and what does that
do to your psyche when you finally
realize that
this whole sort of crazy chaotic
experience
has kind of comes to a close because
everything that you were chasing is
actually
real it's it's alive he is alive he does
still have his father
and then i also think you know how do
you adjust back to normalcy
i mean these kids have gone through so
much they've
they've seen things that most people
don't see
in their single lives let alone in you
know a two-week span or whatever the
timeline is now
and um so i think i'm i'm really
interested in that and then
how the hell are they going to get off
this island
you know like the boat was popped
they're stuck
you know john b's still trying to find
the silver lining and everything which
you know kind of comes to a beautiful
conclusion but i just i'm i'm very
interested to kind of see where that
goes and then obviously
what does young love turn into you know
is it you know
going to be walking into the sunset or
are we gonna see the honest you know
two sense of what it's like to be young
and in love and continue to
see little things be you know wedged in
between or
part of me wants to see john b and sarah
be like a old married couple like
sitting there laughing about something
really dumb
tv trays watching a movie i know it's
like oh let's go
uh watch some interviews today yeah it's
the latest tv show that we should watch
entertainment tonight always